still get warmed up some of you I I here
referencing that I sound tired I think
that's actually the usual case whenever
I begin a stream and then and usually
after I have a granola bar or a few
games in me then the voice changes
change of voice okay so far so book open
Sicilian night Orff and with that black
is saying maybe I'm going to play d 50
do you have the option for this I'm
gonna give it a shot I could get really
crazy meaning well the thing that's
saying that it could get really crazy
the variation I have in mind is a
five-night f5 g6 and maybe like g5 as a
counter to it I know the difference
between Rick g1 and h4 something I
touched on in a previous video that I
had uploaded to the YouTube channel one
that I initially live streamed and then
after taking the recording and uploading
it to youtube money how it's something I
took from twitch and uploaded to the
YouTube channel difference between rook
g1 and h4 I believe that was trying to
recall a player's name t night if i'm
not mistaken can anyone confirm that
anybody recalling this game that i'm
talking about where i played rook g1 and
then g5 was played and i was just at a
loss for finding a constructive plan on
the kingside it just got closed and then
it got really wacky and a typical time
scramble towards the end anyhow oh man
okay well
I don't think I'm in a position to have
things open up do I really want to take
and this this this and hitting my rook
what are the alternatives I can't push
here I'm in a pin let's try this kick
that night away and I think I need
support here so I better go with it I
have my rook around to defend this pond
what if Bishop e7 is played usually at a
move but it's coming with a pretty good
threat where do I want my light square
Bishop I might want to keep them around
okay well I definitely want to keep them
right here now cleanup queenside castle
do i really think i'm going to go Kings
side cleanup queenside castle if there's
a square I really need to pay close
attention to its d for my bishop does
well not to move if there's this knight
that's going to land on c4 I just want
to take it out on one shot so he's done
I'm done moving this guy so what more
can I be looking into well here's
another thing big decision right now
because if I don't take this night there
might be night a five and one of these
nights will be getting here if I think I
could prevent a night from getting here
by playing b 3 i'm crazy a 3 available
Bishop b4 available pins bad stuff
happens all too team white so having
said that do I take this night or do I
play to be three to stop Knight a5 it's
a good question and I don't know if I
have an answer to it well if i take here
that's going to open the beef ah i don't
want that to open up I think if if
there's a file i could tolerate it would
be maybe this one so that said let's
maneuver the night here I guess this
could be played but then I haven't have
night be five so and you know another
thing that would allow me to know that
maybe this is the correct move is just
knowing that I have a space advantage
and maybe keeping some pieces on the
board is not a bad idea for as long as
this night remains here
one thing I won't have to worry about is
this Queen seeing these see file squares
directly so current current position of
the night is just masking the Queen this
Bishop is having to make a basically a
clearance move just to get the rook
involved if I could control this night
do I in in some sense control the game I
wonder or control the queenside activity
for black I'd like to get pushing up
here but that's going to drop this pond
if i play this i think h5 is a good
response although then maybe there is g6
one thing I don't want to allow happen
is after h5 g6 for me to make a silly
move like King b1 and allow for g6 or in
other words I don't want this Queen side
too or the kingside excuse me I want
that too close so I'm looking at the
different pond pushes different
possibilities that exist with the pond
pushes is ripped g1 followed by um this
and then this a good idea I don't know
about that maybe this is a start pond
push here let's try that this is a this
group of four pawns is called a court
grip black has a similar thing going on
in fact all four of these ponds for
black and white are confer fighting for
all four of these squares a group of
four I guess this is a purposeful move
King to be one maybe there's a rook see
one moves should I need some more
support for my sepan and okay now black
is going in that direction okay well
wow wow okay yeah this is a this is a
bit tricky here let's come over here if
Bishop in I think I need to like throw
question in that Bishop real soon oh man
i'm not running out of ideas in this
position we're about equal with the time
neither one of us has moved our king
bishop i'm not sure where I want to go
with I if I'm going to move my bishop
it's just to make a move this night is
going to kill me on c4 if it goes
somewhere over here oh well I don't
think I have much of a choice he's got
to go yeah I can't deal with that night
here I run into tricky tactics i think
all right well this is a bit scary I am
opposite that rook we're going to
probably see knight takes Bishop takes
and then the bishop playing to this
square hitting my rook and I think rook
f1 might be then needed otherwise
there's bishop moves to f3 with the fork
on my broken g4 pond so let's see if
black could figure it out okay well I do
best I think to just get out of the
nonsense and I think if there's nonsense
it would come by way of this pin so get
out of the pin in other words in there
is possibilities for maybe a Bishop to
b6 move let's do this first and well I
think the bishop coming here is a bad
idea now because Bishop b6 is a pretty
annoying threat not just to win the
exchange because there's always a rock
in between move but i think i win the
queen now by force a queen for bishop
and rook so let's do this first my books
are connected it takes i just recapture
and now that d 8 square is a big
problem queen here actually I'm winning
it's I'm winning a queen for a rook or a
bishop I think maybe like Queen here's
that turns out to be the best move
playing to c6 I actually get me so that
turned out to be a tough spot right
there but I believe we did arrive at an
equal middle game interesting let's see
it sit back flip that board and see
about improvements for either one of us
I don't know i think the d5 move is
pretty interesting I've seen it I've
seen it before it really puts throws a
question to my e4 pawn at a moment where
this night is still able to maintain
itself on the f6 square you know because
it given given the time i'm going to be
playing maybe rook g one g five of the
night has to run away and i'll still
have a pawn on e4 helping to control
this particular pawn push by black but
that said I think black is still doing
quite alright now one thing I wondered
about is maybe Bishop here because what
do I do about that threat of just not
only taking of the pond but just giving
check and then I'll have to go on
castled so I think Bishop e7 inserting
this move would you know you're getting
one step closer to development and I
think it's going to force me to come
back to f2 so maybe that's a small
improvement another one to look into is
maybe that if you're going to go with
Knight b6 maybe try to get in b5 but
again I think still with the moves that
were played I think this turns out to be
fine for black like right here take the
night and I think this is where there's
a
a good improvement maybe just take the
night and I was planning on just I
recapture with the bishop so let's say
that was played knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop see six hits the rook and
then as a follow-up a move like Bishop
to b4 and maybe maybe later on like
Queen to a5 I think your bishop is
really well placed on c6 and you're
fully developed you have the rooks
connected there so I think I think going
with that instead of tucking the bishop
back on the on the first rank is going
to be better because now there's some
serious threats which eventually showed
itself in the game but again earlier I
think right here instead of the night
move look into Bishop e7 you're one step
closer to being fully developed once you
are a queen side castle any anyhow just
throwing out some stuff there